[Musica]
se non fosse stato così la mia sarebbe
stata davvero una vita migliore
avrei potuto mangiare scrivere guidare e
giocare alla play
un uomo come tanti più forte più sicuro
avrei accettato con gli amici mangiato
il sushi con la fidanzata sollevato pesi
e portato a spasso il cane avrei fatto
un sacco di cose visto gente sorriso a
tanti
tutto sarebbe stato tutto completamente
diverso se non fossi stato così o forse
no
[Musica]
essere così mi ha reso l'uomo che avrei
voluto davvero guardare allo specchio
essere così mi ha permesso di cadere e
rialzarsi cadere ancora rialzarmi più
forte di prima
senza voler mai smettere di crederci
[Musica]
mi chiamo massimiliano secchi ed ogni
giorno mi conquistò la vita migliore che
avessi mai potuto avere
e tu
[Musica]
[Applauso]
quante volte ci siamo chiesti se non
fossi stato così quante volte vi siete
chiesti se non fosse successo a me io
personalmente da quando ero piccolo così
da quando sono nato mi sono chiesto
perché a me e magari qualcuno affianco
al meglio te che a me di fatto una cosa
che ho capito è che niente accade per
caso e ci è voluto tanto tempo per
capire quanto tutto ciò che viviamo ogni
giorno sia connesso a un qualcosa di più
grande al nostro scopo alla nostra
missione al nostro essere
per tanti anni per la maggior parte
della mia vita ho fatto di tutto per
dimostrare alle persone di essere come
loro ho fatto di tutto per dimostrare di
non essere un errore ho fatto di tutto
per rispondere a quegli sguardi che mi
guardavano con pietismo attraverso le
mie azioni attraverso i miei risultati
attraverso il voler dimostrare il giorno
dopo giorno di essere uguale agli altri
una normalità che per tanti anni mi è
sembrata irraggiungibile nonostante i
miei genitori facessero di tutto per
insegnarmi a fare le cose con quello che
avevo senza concentrarmi su ciò che mi
mancasse però non è facile non è facile
perché ti scontri giorno dopo giorno con
gli sguardi delle persone ti scontri con
il pietismo ti scontri con quel poverino
e allora li fai di tutto per dimostrare
che nonostante la tua disabilità puoi
avere un valore
puoi essere comunque degno di rispetto
il problema è che quando passi la tua
vita a dimostrare qualcosa agli altri
per ri di vista la cosa più importante
se stesso perde di vista le tue emozioni
perde di vista i tuoi sogni perde di
vista le tue aspirazioni
perché si è concentrato su ciò che vedi
è ciò che senti si è concentrato su ciò
che gli altri potrebbero pensare di te
in quel momento e questo mi ha portato
per tanto tempo a soffrire di attacchi
di panico e non capivo perché perché in
realtà quando a sei mesi impari a
vestirsi in varie a mangiare da solo
nonostante non abbia qualche pezzo è
strano poi a 14 anni renderti conto di
non poter stare in mezzo alle persone
perché subito l'ansia ti butta giù e ti
fa venire voglia di scappare
è frustrante riuscire a accettare il
fatto che apparentemente tu adesso si è
diventato indipendente ma che ciò che le
persone non vedono e la sofferenza che
hai dentro ti giudicano per ciò che è
esterno ma non hanno idea di cosa voglia
dire dentro di te vivere una condizione
come questa per la quale per 17 anni e
mezzo non puoi muoverti in autonomia
perché hai una carrozzina spinta e
quindi in realtà a commenti hanno dei
tristi di genitori perché i miei
genitori per quanto abbiamo fatto di
tutto per spronarmi mi hanno avvisato
per non farmi illudere che sarebbe stato
difficile avere una vita normale sarebbe
stato difficile avere degli amici perché
a 14 anni gli amici non vengono aperti a
casa con la carrozzina preferiscono
uscire con le ragazze è una ragazza non
viene a spingere la tua carrozzina non
ti bussa a casa per dire salve signori
vorremmo vorrei conoscere massimiliano
vorrei uscire con lui te lo puoi
scordare e figurati quali saranno le
aziende che decideranno di assumere te
in un contesto in cui le barriere
architettoniche sono già preventive di
per sé figuriamoci poi gli spazi interni
figuriamoci cosa potrei fare
effettivamente a livello fisico
ecco tutte queste cose mi hanno
condizionato al punto da
passare come vi ho detto la maggior
parte della mia vita a soffrire di
attacchi di panico sto facendo di tutto
per superare la mia disabilità loro
fatto fisicamente ma ho imparato una
cosa molto importante
grazie a questi attacchi di panico la
differenza tra superare una situazione
ad accettarla superarla vuol dire
riuscire a fare delle cose nonostante
era più una cosa fisica nei miei
confronti
mentre accettarla era una cosa più
spirituale
vuol dire che la mia anima aveva capito
che in realtà io fossi nato così per un
motivo ben preciso
ho iniziato a chiedermi quali fossero le
cose che mi facevano più paura e tra
queste c'era l essere visto con altre
persone con disabilità una cosa assurda
apparentemente perché lì sarebbe dovuto
essere potenzialmente più nascosto e
invece no io non volevo essere visto
come il disabile questo mi ha portato a
trovarmi in delle situazioni a mettermi
nelle situazioni in cui dovevo
dimostrare di non essere più a livello
della normalità ma di superare la
normalità e grazie a questo ho
incontrato delle persone dei ragazzi che
mentre giocavo ai videogiochi la mia più
grande passione perché quando avevo
quattro anni
i miei genitori mi hanno regalato il
primo computer affinché io potessi
scrivere con la tastiera e non avessi
problemi a scuola ho incontrato delle
persone che fino a quando ero al loro
livello
mi chiamavano ero marsero loro amico ma
quando ho superato il loro livello
nonostante loro giocassero con dieci
dita e io con due gomiti e un piede
hanno iniziato a darmi dello storpio
dell'handicappato per l'errore della
natura perché sapevano che le nostre
prestazioni dipendono dalle nostre
emozioni allora facevano di tutto per
distruggermi emotivamente affinché
potessero vincere su internet è facile
poi decidere di cambiare nickname
e le persone non ti conoscono più ti
inventi una nuova storia una nuova vita
oppure le affronti avrei voluto
affrontarli ma non avevo la forza per
farlo
e allora ho cambiato nic per diversi
anni ho continuato a vincere
a scavalcare le vette prima italiani poi
europee fino a quando non sono arrivato
a battere i primi record del mondo in
quel momento ho deciso di uscire allo
scoperto creato un canale in cui mi
chiamavo the endless gamer il giocatore
senza mani e iniziato a sfidare il mondo
intero facendogli capire che la
disabilità non volesse dire non poter
fare le cose ma dover trovare
semplicemente un modo diverso per vivere
la vita due ragazzi mi hanno dato
grazie a questo canale una delle lezioni
più importanti che io potessi apprendere
perché inizialmente io prendiamo anche
in giro le altre persone mi volevo
rifare di tutta quella sofferenza
questi due ragazzi però hanno fatto due
video nei loro canali dove mi
ringraziavano perché fino a quel momento
fino a quando non avranno visto i miei
video loro mostravano solo il loro viso
e non mostravano le loro mani a 1
mancava una mano un altro in una manovra
soltanto due dita
anche loro come vi ho detto mi hanno
insegnato una delle lezioni più
importanti perché mi hanno fatto capire
che ciò che ci fa fare la differenza
come esseri umani non è ciò che
dimostriamo di avere o di fare in più
rispetto agli altri ma ciò che facciamo
per gli altri e in quel momento la mia
vita è cambiata è cambiata radicalmente
perché ho deciso che la mia disabilità
mi sarebbe servita per attirare
l'attenzione delle persone fargli capire
che nel momento in cui provassero pena
per me
in realtà provano quell'emozione
semplicemente perché nella mia
condizione
credevano di non poter vivere una vita
dignitosa e allora lì sono entrato nel
mondo del coaching della formazione e
soprattutto nel mondo delle persone nel
mondo dell'aiuto alla persona
stiamo parlando oggi di connessioni e vi
farò vedere qualche foto per farvi
capire come nel momento in cui noi
scendiamo che significato dare alla
nostra storia
tanti puntini possono diventare un
disegno meraviglioso io credo
sinceramente
che non esistano esperienze belle ed
esperienze brute esistono esperienze e
poi siamo noi a scegliere siamo noi a
decidere in che modo vederle e che il
significato darle questo ero io
evidentemente non io
nel senso che i miei genitori hanno
sempre fatto di tutto per farmi mettere
le protesi io le ho sempre odiato perché
mi chiedevo come faccio a vivere felice
se mi avete insegnato a essere così
autonomo con il mio corpo era già con le
protesi non potevo esserlo non potevo
vestirmi non potevo andare in bagno non
potevo mangiare da solo e vedete lo
sguardo di quel bambino ma anche questo
mi è servito perché se non avessi
vissuto tutto questo oggi non sarei
stato costretto a lavorare sulla mia
identità sulla fermarmi per quello che
sono e per quello che voglio essere
nella maniera più autentica più sincera
il più naturale possibile
qua erano le prime prove di guida per
tanti anni mi hanno detto che non avrei
mai avuto la possibilità di guidare in
realtà oggi è da dieci anni guido anche
la macchina e questo è stato un
grandissimo cambiamento per la mia vita
perché grazie alla macchina posso
viaggiare per tutta italia e non solo è
incontrare tran tantissime persone
questi erano i miei amici
prendete la mia faccia a 16 17 anni
se io quando anzi guardo queste foto
veramente mi sembra di guardare una
persona diversa una persona che non si
può muovere da sola una persona che non
si può esprimere in maniera veramente
autentica perché ha paura che
esprimendosi e dicendo quello che prova
veramente rischia di valere se quel
pezzo lì perché magari si offende
qualcuno gli amici oi genitori i parenti
non lo spostiamo più ma poi c'è questo
che grazie agli attacchi di panico si è
chiuso a casa ha iniziato a giocare
giocare giocare ed è diventato campione
del mondo che grazie ai videogiochi ha
capito l'importanza della condivisione
l'importanza di donarsi per dare valore
alla vita delle persone e che grazie
videogiochi ha imparato l'inglese fino
ad andare a singapore e raggiungere il
terzo posto al campionato del mondo di
mappe mentali quell'uomo che ha avuto la
fortuna per nove mesi di parlare a
questo bambino questi sono i piedi di
gesù gesù e e mio figlio che è morto ha
lasciato il suo corpo a nove mesi quando
ho preso in braccio per la prima volta
gesù è lui non poteva già più ridere
perché era già morto ma io gli ho fatto
una promessa
vi ho promesso che lui avrebbe riso
attraverso tutti gli sguardi e tutti i
visi delle persone che io da quel
momento in poi avrei aiutato
partendo dai bambini perché i bambini
tante volte vengono visti come il nostro
futuro ma in realtà sono il nostro
presente ed ecco che oggi la onlus ha il
suo nome gesù e vive proprio perché gesù
e vive attraverso tutti i bambini che
noi aiutiamo tutto questo non sarebbe
stato possibile se non fossi nato così
tutto questo non sarebbe stato possibile
se io per tanti anni non avessi sofferto
perché non fosse autonomo questo non
sarebbe stato possibile se io per tanti
anni non avessi provato la frustrazione
di essere giudicato perché forse non mi
sarei impegnato così tanto nel capire
che il mio valore e non dipendesse da
ciò che gli altri credessero di me ma da
ciò che io credessi di me e decidessi di
fare mi ha portato anche a ricevere il
premio del quale vi hanno parlato nella
mia introduzione quindi il premio come
cavaliere della repubblica italiana
ma vi voglio fare vedere l'ultima slide
è la slide forse più importante di tutte
queste è questa non c'è niente
e non c'è niente perché io credo che non
ci sia niente di più importante del
presente
tutto ciò che avete visto è il mio
passato e la mia storia
questo è il presente è presente che
costruiamo ogni giorno è presente che
stiamo costruendo in questo istante e
quello che proviamo momento dopo momento
e oggi credo che veramente il presente
sia ciò che ci manca di più il tempo per
fermarci e chiederci ma quello che sto
vivendo è veramente ciò che mi rende
felice ma sono veramente fiero di ciò
che sono
bloccare un attimino quella todolist con
la lista delle cose da fare è
concentrarci un po sulla nostra tubi
list la lista di ciò che vogliamo essere
ma vi lascio con questa slide anche
perché è bianca e luminosa e ognuno di
noi ha degli spazi nel nostro cuore che
sono un po bue
ecco io credo che il buio la sofferenza
che abbiamo vissuto
abbiamo un grandissimo dono che è quello
di costringerci a trovare la luce a
riempirlo a trovare le risorse per
potere illuminare quelle sofferenze e il
mio augurio per tutti voi e che
riusciate a dare un senso a tutto quello
che avete vissuto perché un senso lo sa
dare luce alla vostra vita e alla vita
di tutte le persone che incontrate ogni
giorno e con questo vi ringrazio
[Applauso]